oh my God are we matching I love you so
much
[Music]
oh good give me some blush oh my God
the scream fam the fam fam you are the
fam that's the most amazing thing of it
all like you're such a big part of this
franchise I just introduced myself as
Casey Becker to someone you did I was
like hi Casey Becker here oh Red Light
confession
Courtney and Melissa
you drew yeah I Ghost Face people all
the time but have you ever ghosted
someone
come on like a guy I mean like yeah even
like even sometimes like not even guys
friends I'm like I have left to party
without saying goodbye but no tell us
about it
someone is adding stress
I'm like I actually don't need that
energy in my life do you tell them that
are you no I just stop answering texts
good to know Melissa
I was watching you get your star and I'm
watching you and Lisa and Jennifer it
was kind of like our camaraderie the way
we were on friends that was my girls and
I was so happy that they showed up I
know that I knew that they would of
course but it was raining and who really
wants to speak in public but and Laura
spook spoke as well and I've known her
forever as
you know I'm not going to say as well
again but
um I it was just great I felt so
supported and I know I'm so nice and
everything like I was very emotional for
sure and I know my dad was there because
I was talking about my mom and my dad
and then all of a sudden uh you know he
builds swimming pools for a living and
as I was talking about how much you love
it boom all this water felt someone goes
that's your dad it was pretty it was
incredible I'm not even sure I believe
in that kind of stuff
I do know I was gonna say I feel like I
believe in that I think I do I just met
from hearing that story I don't know
either here is where the water like
really broke for me pun intended was
when I saw Coco there oh my
I mean what was it like to have her
there it felt so good the things I do
are embarrassing still and but she was
proud and it made me so happy that she
wanted to take I mean she was willing to
take a picture with me and hug me and
then you've got this wonderful man there
too yeah it was so sweet he flew over
from London that's where he lives I
recently tried to date someone and they
lived in Los Angeles and I was like this
is just not gonna work right now because
I can't ever get out there and I'm just
I still have no libido but I was like I
convinced myself like oh long distance
is so hard as long as you have trust
then I think it doesn't matter where you
are you can be yourself and yet be
excited when you see each other but let
me go back to advice because I I really
want to know how did you build the trust
he moved to LA
to be in this relationship we got
engaged and within two years and we
broke up for six months and he moved to
London in the process of this breakup
and then we got back together and he
didn't really want to move back to LA so
then we had to make it work in that way
during covid that was I don't know maybe
like eight months we didn't see each
other we talk every day we face time we
see each other maybe once a month Jay's
Shetty was on our show and I was reading
his book his new book The Eight rules of
Love Are Rules of love and I just love
it so much because so much of it is
about your relationship with yourself
and how to prioritize that one in your
own security and confidence and you know
the things you can control it's so damn
healthy and I love that because if you
make it all about the other person then
it can be taken away in a moment's
notice I was like oh I know this I'm
into this I'm so with this and then I
found the word trust and I started
hysterically crying and I was like
that's my problem I've lost the ability
to trust someone is it time that leads
to trust well to me
trust is demonstr like something that
that is demonstrated let's say like I
was cheated on by an ex-boyfriend I
would never say oh then that means my
husband is going to cheat on me because
he's a different man agreed you don't
put someone else's baggage on someone
else but I think a lot of people do yes
because you project that you know your
trauma or your own insecurities on to
another person and I think that's not
fair I couldn't agree more what do you
love about your relationship with your
husband I mean we've been together
for almost 12 years we're both
completely different human beings like
completely different from when we met
but I feel like with us it's always been
that we want to continue to grow
together it's all about compromise a Red
Light confession hold on what's on your
night
s you better see a picture of me can I
say two things a home court candle and
earplugs foamy soft mushy malleable ones
if you were earplugs you got to get the
ones that are silicone I wear Macs oh no
no I'm a foamy what's wrong with foam
are you kidding
you smooshing and then it expands you
exactly and I feel like the others
you just take them and you just do a
quick mold will you try it I would be
down where can we do a group please and
then we can just call each other the
earplugs because it's going to change
your life the ear plugs oh red light red
light what's the most disgusting
would you do it again when Coco was
really young and she knew she was like
for I don't know how long but it seemed
if she was in pain so is this okay to
say is that my finger but this one 100
and I'll do it a thousand times again me
too I don't think that's disgusting at
all I'm not going to say what is your
disgusting thing no because it's
actually disgusting you guys should we
be the judge of that I've cloned a lot
of toilets in my life a lot a lot
it's time for Bonnie's review Ronnie
what'd you think oh I love Scream Six I
think this was the best one yet oh
Ghostface a run for his money and I
loved it you are such a badass in the
movie and it's like you're so strong and
you're so Alpha and protective of your
amazing sister of the great Jenna Ortega
and then you have that scene that set
piece with Ghostface that's the most
athletic it reminded me of like Kill
Bill level stuff no I'm serious it's
like again you were agile as a cat and
you were so Fierce and you seemed
unafraid remember Casey she didn't fare
so well like Gail takes no crap all the
ghost face that they've been around too
long and she is was tired of it like
enough yeah she's been waiting for this
Moment by the way is it true did you
tell Wes you could be I mean I had to
because I was on Family Ties I'd been
that's all I had done and then I was on
screen I mean Instagram what's it called
up friends What's that show called
um but I had to write him a letter no I
think I said I trust me I'm a or
something I I want to know how you being
Drew Barrymore yes say I'm willing to do
this movie and die in the first scene
like I want to know how that happened I
thought it was going to be one of the
best films of that genre ever made and I
wanted to do everything I could to take
away the Trope of you believe
this character will make it through what
a Visionary like honestly that's really
admirable of you well six gosh darn
films later
hello I'm glad it all worked out I
really want to put the group text of the
earplugs together is that is that good
is that okay yeah we can have all we can
you know we could just call the chain
plugs let's do it I like it I like that
I love it you are so beautiful and sexy
and Fierce and capable and you make me
feel like everything's gonna be okay can
I ask you really quickly how the hell
you act that I don't know fake it till
you make it because I was very nervous
all through shooting these two movies
I think I just um
I'm surrounded by great people Melissa
the second I met her I was like I just
love this girl I could tell she's cool
she's the most independent person it's
true it's the independence that's what I
smell there's some there's a scent you
leave Pepe Le Pew I love you guys
Happy sex movies
this show for you take it with you I'll
be seeing you
[Music]
thank you